[Music]
good afternoon I'm Jeffrey phango I'm a
technique manager on the Android studio
team where I'm in charge of the D 8 r8
compiler project so last year a lot
happens in compiler space we added
incremental dexing which makes your
debugger built faster we added these
sugaring of Java 8 language features so
you can now use Java 8 features like
lambdas in all the versions of Android
we added a new deck sir which compiles
your Java bytecode to Delphic byte code
that runs from the art runtime we added
a new shrink and optimizer called r8 and
we added : specific optimizations
Internet as well and then today we also
have the Android app bundle and so I
want to talk to you about all of these
show how it works inside Gradle and give
you some tips of things you need to know
when you start using these new tools so
let's first start looking at incremental
dexing so here you have a very very
simplified version of what happens in
Gradle when the compiler runs so first
we run either Java C or Kotlin C to take
your Java or Copeland source code and
generate Java bytecode and then we run
DX that takes the Java bytecode and
produces Delphic bytecode now nice thing
that in Gradle because of Gradle and
JetBrains work Java C and Colton see are
actually incremental and that means that
if you change one source file it only
compiles that one source file and
potentially any sources that have
different semantics based on that change
now unfortunately in Android studio and
Gradle before 3.0 DX didn't do any
incremental work so it still took all
your Java class files and compiled each
one of them two dalvik bytecode even if
those class files hadn't changed so in
Android studio 3.0 and above we actually
changed it so that we can be incremental
so we'd split DX into two steps one that
take
the Java bytecode and compiles it to the
Delphic bytecode and we do that per
class file so we actually generate now
one dex file per class file and that way
that step can be incremental and then
after that we take all those codex files
and merge them into a single or multiple
Dex files if needed and the reason this
works is that most of the time spent
indexing is actually in the compilation
space where we take the Java bytecode
which is a stack based machine to
Delphic bytecode which is register base
and then the Dex merging is more or less
like a fancy concat and so that's a lot
faster and so we enabled this by default
in your debug built in release builds we
don't do that and so you pay a little
bit extra for the initial build because
we need to generate more files but then
each incremental build that you do
afterwards it's a lot faster just
because we have to do less work there
are some things you need to be aware of
though so Java C and cotton C are only
incremental when you are not using
annotation processors anytime you enable
annotation processors these annotation
processors can reach into any part of
your source and so we cannot make that
incremental now Gradle is working hard
to make that support it and so in Gradle
4.7 they introduced a preliminary
support for incremental annotation
processors this requires some work by
the annotation processor to support that
because annotation processor needs to
tell Gradle how incremental it can be
and so what I'd like to ask you all is
if you are an annotation processor
writer look at the stuff that Gradle is
doing and see if you can support that
and if you're using annotation
processors please read out to the
developers of those that they should
look at this because it will really
really speed up your builds ok so let's
go on to the sugaring what is the sugar
ring
we hear from all people they have it
many times that they want to use modern
Java features and Java aid like lambdas
default methods in interfaces try with
resources etc unfortunately a lot of
these features require a new bytecode
and language API to support them and of
course a lot of Android device out there
run all the versions of the dalvik VM
that doesn't yet support these and but
developers really want to use these
features especially as you start using
new frameworks like reactive extensions
now I'm not sure exactly what these
libraries do but they use a lot of
callbacks and would be much nicer if you
can use lambdas there and so what we do
with the sugar is we take the bytecode
and calls that are generated by these
new features in the Java compiler and we
convert them to something that is
supported in the old system so for
instance if you use a lambda and Java 8
we can take that and replace it with a
class as if you her to handwrite it so
that you don't have to handwrite it and
we do it for you
so let's take a look at how that works
in practice and so let's switch the demo
ok so here I have an Android studio
project that is just created by
following the wizards and selecting a
basic activity and so if you go to the
module in the module settings you see
that I have set the source language to
1.8 and now it will allow me to write
Java 8 language features and if you do
this Gradle automatically figures out
that it needs to run this sugar for you
and so here I have some code I have a
floating action button that I want to
hook up some code to but when you click
it and now because I use Java 8 I don't
have to write new onclicklistener and
implement the whole interface instead I
can just write a lambda and have it in
be invoked so if I go and look at the
output of the Java C compiler there's a
mainactivity look glass and I can copy
that path there is a tool in a Java JDK
called Java P which allows you to take a
class file and look at the byte code
that's in there and so I'll run that and
because it generates a lot of output
I'll pipe it to a file and then I'm
opening it in my favorite IDE Android
studio and so if you haven't looked at
Java bytecode don't be afraid it's still
pretty high level it's kind of readable
the only thing that's not there is for
loops if statements and so on but like
if you read through it is still pretty
understandable so there's a lot of
constants that we're just gonna skip
over and then here we have the oncreate
method that we were looking at and in
first school here you see that there's a
virtual call to the set onclicklistener
that's the thing where we passed our
lambda two and then see that the
argument before that is this
invokedynamic instruction and it tells
us that it's gonna pass this
onclicklistener so what is invoke
dynamic it's a nice feature in the java
vm that is kind of reflective so instead
of the vm immediately invoking your
method it allows the application to
provide a hook in there and dispatch the
method any way you want and so and in
Java they have these things called meta
factories that they use to implement
these features and so there is this
specific lambda meta Factory and you see
that here in the bottom of the file that
scatters argument the view and then it
passes to this lambda oncreate method
which we can see here as well and if you
look carefully you see that it actually
has the the snack bar codes that we had
in the body of our lambda so what's
going on here is that the first time the
app is run on the JVM it knows that it
needs to call this lambda meta Factory
and that thing will actually generate
the class that implements the interface
on the fly and then it will call that
for the rest of the program
now the parameters that that takes time
at run time adds more memory at runtime
so we don't do that on Android even a
newer version of Android and of course
an old version of Android they don't
know about this invoke dynamic
instruction or the meta Factory so
instead the sugar will take care of this
so let's take a look at what happened in
this project when we built it using the
sugar so I'm going to open the apk
there's this tool since in Android
studio 3.0 above called the apk analyzer
and it allows you to look inside the apk
both for file size of your resources but
also to see what's inside the the Dex
code that's going to run on the device
so here I see all the packages in the
Dex codes and I'm going to navigate to
my main activity and then on create
method and I'm gonna say show byte code
so you see byte code that is kind of
similar to Java byte code there's a
couple differences instead of using
stack based machines we have registers
but if you don't are not familiar with
that don't worry about that so at the
end of the method we see the same call
to the set onclicklistener but the big
difference is that one line above it
doesn't show invoke dynamic or invoke
custom as it would be on Android
instead it calls this magic class - -
dollar lambda and then it gets the
interface field of that so let's take a
look at that class so you see that the
class is right along there and so what
we see in the class is that it
implements the own click listener
interface it has a static field instance
and then it has the onclick method for
the onclick listener interface and all
it does it's called the generated method
that contains method body of our lambda
and so now there's no Java 8 features no
Java 8 byte code in
code and we can execute it on any
Android version even as low as Ice Cream
Sandwich
okay so let's switch back to the slides
so this is how that is integrated into
the Gradle build system after the Java C
compiler runs we run the separate
process called D sugar all right what it
does it reads the Java bytecode
it takes out all these functions that
are not supported emits new byte codes
and then we pass it on to DX and so the
rest of the pipeline doesn't have to
know anything about the sugaring so this
is nice you can use new Java 8 features
there's a couple things you need to be
aware of if you do your own bytecode
transformations so there's people who do
their own bytecode transformations for
code injection crash reporting etc
because we run the sugar we run your
bytecode transformations after the sugar
which means that you see all our crazy
patterns like the the dollar lambda code
when you're doing your own processing so
be aware of that if you're doing your
own bytecode transformations ok so let's
move on to da da it is our new texture
as I said Android it runs just a dell
'fuck bytecode not Java bytecode and
Dextre is the tool that takes java
bytecodes
from the stack based machine and
converts it into dalvik bytecode which
is register base we had this tool before
called DX but it's been was pretty old
people had problems with it and so we
decided to build a new version called d8
and so the reason we build it is we want
to have faster compilation because
everybody always wants faster builds we
wanted to generate smaller code and give
people better Diagnostics by better
Diagnostics I mean both the error
messages that you get when you're
running the compiler as well as better
debug information that when you're
running your app in the debugger that
you have a better understanding of what
is going on ok so how is d8 integrated
into the Gradle build system
it's actually quite similar to what DX
is we just swap out the x-48 the
interesting thing there is that in
Android Co 3.2 we also integrate the D
sugaring step into D 8 so that's saves
us a round trip between write the
reading and writing the class files and
so it will provide provides more speed
up the side-effect of death though is
that if you're writing your own byte
code rewriters we now run them before d8
which means that your byte code
rewriters have to support the Java 8
language okay so let's look at a demo of
D 8 in action
okay so here have another project that I
just created using the project Wizards
and because I'm using Android studio 3.2
d8 is already enabled by default
so I ever went into the Gradle property
files and I explicitly disable d8
because I want to show you behavior of
DX before we use da so in my main
application
I added some code to my own click
listener to have the snack bar print a
custom message and then I have a method
get message and I set a breakpoint and
so let's look at that when I run it in
the emulator on the debugger
okay so the app is running I'm gonna hit
the button so that I get hit the
breakpoint so I initialize X to be the
length of the empty string so that
should be zero and so in the if
statement I expect to step through the
true case and of course that's what
happens and I'm gonna step further this
is bizarre right like I don't expect my
code to evaluate both the true and false
case so that's kind of weird so let's
see what happens if I run and see what
the output is so luckily the output on
the screen is hello there what I
expected but there was something weird
going on what what was going on
okay so let's remove this and sinker
Gradle build so that we're switching to
d8 and let's stop that and redeploy it
so while this is going on so in DX we
had this issue and it was actually a
very high start bug report and the
reason it was happening is that not only
is the the VM very different between
stack and register the way that debug
information is stored in Java the class
files in dalvik is very different and in
Java it starts with the instructions and
in dalvik it's a state machine and so we
had to translate bolts from register
stack to register and the debug
information and so sometimes information
got lost so like it might end up with a
single return statements in the Delphic
bytecode and then we couldn't map that
in the debug information in d8 we track
all the debug information carefully and
we have a whole system of assertions to
make sure that we don't lose debug
information so let's hit the button here
we're hitting the breakpoint again we
step through we get into the truth
branch and we jump out of it
thank you
okay so let's switch back to the slides
so we have done a lot of work on d8 it
has better debug information but it's
also faster so here is some data around
build time on the Google nest app so we
ship d8 as a preview in under studio 3.1
there were not always faster but we had
a lot more work since 3.1 and so in 3.2
on average were about 16 percent faster
in clean builds and of course
incremental builds like the Delta is
smaller because there's less code to
compile so still 16 percent this is
pretty nice so d8 is already widely used
if you're using Android P beta that was
released yesterday Android T is
completely built with d8 the Google Docs
app is already built with the AIDS and
then Google Photos is right now in
canary using d8 and many more Google
Apps will follow soon okay so let's move
over to RA
all right is our new shrinker so why you
want to shrink ur so most people who
build apps they use a lot of libraries
like Google guava Apache Commons Arak
Java and you usually don't use that full
library you might use maybe 10 15
percent of the library yet if you ship
it as is you would be shipping all that
code that you don't use and application
size is important right people don't
want to pay for it in their bandwidth it
uses disk space on the device and so the
smaller app the better and there was a
previous solution to this the ProGuard
tool but we heard some people that they
had issues with it it was taking a long
time the code wasn't as small as they
wish it didn't really understand Android
and so we invested in building a new
shrinker we also made the error messages
clearer and of course we understood that
people are already using ProGuard and so
we decided that we wanted to be
are compatible and so we understand all
of programs keep rules so how does
ProGuard work so before so whoever ate
works so before in Gradle we would run
ProGuard between your java compilation
and the next generation and the reason
for that is that ProGuard is a java to
java compilation and so this added more
time to your build in Android studio 3.2
you can enable our eight it's still
experimental you can enable it using
this setting and what will happen is it
will replace ProGuard G sugar d8 with
one single process r8 that does all of
those steps in one go so we ran r8 on
several taps internally this is the nest
app data so by just swapping ProGuard
for RA we're able to save 100k on the
Dex file size and save our 25% in
compilation time now the nest app is
highly optimized it has very specific
program keep rules and still we're able
to save quite a bit of space we also run
this on some of the system apps that are
shipping with the Android OS and on
average were able to save 25% of the Dex
file size by just swapping ProGuard with
r8 so of course last year we announced
that Coplin is now a support language on
Android and so we figured we need to do
something for Koplin as well Copelan is
an amazing language it allows you to
write very succinctly in code and it's
so powerful it needs to generate a lot
of bytecode and so we looked into places
with we could shrink that further than
the standard and analysis and so we
found a couple places where we could do
things like class merging especially
around lambdas we do more enormous
analysis etc and so let's take a look at
that in a demo
okay so here I have a Copeland
application for those of you haven't
programmed Copeland this is a data class
which is a class that it generates a lot
of code for you so you have a couple
fields here that are really properties
so it generates getters and setters
equals get hash code etc and then here I
have an extension method that tells it
that if I see a collection of that's
instantiated to the type class car add
this extra method that allows me to
search for make and model and so in the
class I'm using like the sequence
operators of Copeland to do a couple
filters and group eyes now normally you
wouldn't write these many filters in a
row you would for you just put all the
boolean logic in one filter but I wanted
to show you what happens with multiple
filters so normally Copeland will
compile each of these lambdas into its
own class and so each Lam that you use
at a new class and that's not really
what you want in a dex file because you
always want to keep the methods
reference count low so let's take a look
at what happens when we do with our
eight so in this project enabled our
eight we're setting this property and
let's take a look what happens in the
output apk so here Mike classes.dex
again the main activity and I I added a
call to that method in the oncreate
method and so here in the oncreate
method you see that there is this new
instance to this lambda group class and
the interesting is that that lambda
group class is not defined in a package
it's defined at the top level so let's
take a look at that here in the apx file
there is this todo lambda file a class
and you see it implements the Copeland
function one interface and it has two
instance fields one which is of type
object is named capture
and the other one is ID and then the
constructor takes both the ID and the
objects and sets the variables and then
here in the invoke method we see that it
has this packed switch and so what we're
doing is we were generating basically
the byte code equivalent of a switch
statement we switch over the ID that was
passed into the constructor to figure
out which piece of code to call and so
if you scroll through here you'll see
that the call to get here the the
property read it model are all in this
piece of code and then you see here that
we have the switch and so what's going
on is we find that we have lambdas that
are of the same signature basically they
implement the same interface and they
have the same capture variables and so
we can take all the different lambdas
and merge them into one class which
allows you to have less metadata and
less method references
okay so let's switch back to the slides
so yeah Kotlin is let's go back one so
Koplin is something we were very
important insight about and it's
becoming more and more important and so
with our rate we're going to keep adding
new optimizations for Copland we're
doing said the lambda merging no
reference no analysis and we're adding
many more and so hopefully our rate will
really help you get your cotton code
even smaller actually we announced
Android app bundle yesterday one of the
things that comes with Android app
bundle is dynamic features and so you
cannot only split your apk by resources
languages etc you can now also split
your features into multiple apks and
that's of course great because not
everybody uses every feature of your app
and not a downside and we heard this
already with instant apps last year
instead it makes it harder to
run ProGuard or r8 over your app because
these tools they are based on doing
whole program analysis and now you don't
have a single program anymore and so
what we came up with is a way to take
all your different features add them and
pass them as one command line into
ProGuard or r8 so that it is effectively
a whole program and then progitarr a it
will spit out a single jar or dex file
and then we can take that information
the ProGuard mapping file and the
original feature jars and bit that
information you have enough data to
reconstitute the different Dex files and
so we have this new deck splitter which
is based on the da gate code base and it
will spit out that whole program again
into different modules and now you can
apply shrinking and optimizations to
your features as well so this is coming
soon it will be in Androids you have 3.2
by the time it reaches stable so we
looked at a whole bunch of different
compiler work that we've done over the
last year some of it is already stable
incremental dexing it was introduced
Android 3.0 the sugar stand alone was
introduced in 3.0 in Android studio at
3.2 we're enabling d8 and D sugaring as
part of that and then in hundred series
3.2 we're introducing r8 as an
experimental feature please use it we
announced that DX will be deprecated as
soon as we find no more major issues in
NDA so for you in a year or so DX will
be gone so we'd like you to try it out
file box so if you go in Android studio
to the help menu there is a submit
feedback option which will immediately
jump you dump you into the issue tracker
and then you can easily file bug our
team is very responsive to these bugs
there is another session tomorrow
that's called effective program keep
rules for smaller applications
and it's basically how to on how to
start using ProGuard or RA by one of the
developers of the are on the Irate team
please fill out the survey on google
chrome IO scheduled about this talk as
well thanks everybody
[Music]